welcome to this video against Jerome and
this is completely even match at least
with current ratings okay I'm sure I'm
sticking with my Sicilian okay yeah
people and people tend to replace u 3m
on e6 which is understandable that's
also the move I you recommend to my
students if they are asking for
something a little bit of the beaten
track of the of their open I think it's
a very very sensible way to play I think
you can't play that only have six it's
sharp yeah we transpose into our
advanced french maybe takes on g6 nope
can I just grab stuff here I think I can
oh wow that's nice Chad blundering stuff
here no um I'm Oh blundering stuff I can
play this here right
so he gave me the two bishops that was
really nice of him.but my king it's a
little bit off I wonder I wonder how to
play that King g8 rook f8 or like what
g6 King g7 the other look to evade now
that's one move longer let's do that and
now I really should go we five before
you before you manages to get stuff
consolidated okay so while I'd get sharp
now t4 like I have to play that move
anyway so let's do it where you going I
fig if I check here does he have a
tactic something crazy nope Bishop hangs
so something with III would be cute but
by Bishop is hanging first to be six
yeah probably that's right here and now
I thought rook e8 43 and that looks that
looks fine yeah we've got equal material
but I've got this monstrous bishop there
on b6 what about rook c8 I could have
played rook c8 here huh and maybe Bishop
d3 then alright still what's interesting
I should have considered that move
but I care that did that has to be a
good position here yes but I can move
the Queen to e5 something like that I
can also take I mean the end game is
this end game is just good actually so
why not and why not just do this at that
night has no square and move like a
fourth sunset by roxy one Roxy one
Bishop a form
and they have King f65 that's also
important my king is quicker and joining
the action ok so a for he wants to go to
deform hmm yep so and I guess invasion
time he still cannot move the bishop
there's some way to get we should be
five going no not yet other group to see
eight is a possibility and 94 I wonder
it says something great I can do there
okay let's play that move not thing for
too long 96 I can take and other look to
c 2 and then threatening this taking on
d4 and Roxy to now I think it should be
a thread
check so look sit two hours him escaping
this e7 King f7 now I don't see it let's
do it he's seven even look it might be
all might be on check check check check
check I had actually winning e seven
rookie to as possible it's made
check
and maybe just rookie one maybe that is
what he wants to do hmm no but if I take
it to now Queens forget to check time
morning it's not a wind funny enough
hmm didn't really think about this here
I hope I have not screwed this up it
would be kind of heartbreaking
so what is that some kind of threat or
not why is taking b7 Anna amazing really
amazing yeah that's still pretty good
check check no check check white
forfeits on time well yeah that was
there was a screw up here I mean here
I'm ready just winning this thing and
okay I think that that's okay check
check this it actually does win
everything that what I'm doing is
winning it's funny yeah okay then I
didn't really screw it up that's some
reassuring I mean I probably had
something better but the comp is always
on mine is too which is Chinese reliable
chat correct here okay so let's let's
check a bit of this and that capture on
c5 it's not very very common but not a
not bad I went to f6 I really don't know
if that is correct I'm not really
playing this opening so frequently that
that that looks ok that looks okay for
me check out the engine is even giving
this check
yeah it's definitely interesting black
keeping those pawns here this is the
line by the engine that's a great
position can even get the King to d6
very nice but okay that it's also not a
problem because the bishop pair and the
center discount for something yeah you
five yeah exactly this is happening and
backpack yeah now look see a German
actually have done that immediately he
is forced to do this and now whoopsie to
was just strong it was a better version
of this game basically no no I'm going
back to that idea i'm still in a very
good shape other other continuation was
just far more convincing okay well
thanks for watching